les policiers sont omniprésents sur tous
les écrans de la télévision le flic est
aujourd'hui devenu un personnage
emblématique sur tf1 passe navarro
colombo julie lescaut france 2 accueille
maigret le commissaire massar france 3
diffuse des aventures de derrick partout
on enquête et nous n'avons pas résisté à
la vague montante des commissaires à
l'affût christine lenief ont beau
détective s'est lancé sur les traces de
ces fins limiers avec toutefois l'aide
de marc gallier qui épousent la vie
l'oeuvre et l'éthique de colonies
c'est la première fois que je mène une
enquête ici en france je suis l'un des
plus vieux flic de la télévision
américaine
première enquête remonte à 1968 et je
débarquais sur votre petit écran sur tf1
plus exactement en 1972 aujourd'hui je
suis regardé par plus de 3 milliards de
téléspectateurs dans le monde
et pourtant en trente ans j'ai pas
tellement changé en ce qui le concerne
en revanche les flics des séries
policières françaises ont
considérablement évolué
le tout premier souvenez vous
cette année c'est rebours elle a déjà
prêté par raymond soubie la première
diffusion des cinq dernières minutes
date de 1958 bois elle est toujours
flanqué de son fidèle gardien
il faudra faire une photo d'accord à
première vue je pense que ça ne pose pas
de problème je suis s'il semble assez
évident pour elle c'est donc à l'époque
et une image du flic français
les mesures ont la mine renfrognée et
l'inoubliable mimiques pour dire en
tapant du poing pour du soutien à la
mort de souplex en 1972 c'est jacques de
bari qui va le remplacer
il devient alors le commissaire cabrol
joubert ambiance pittoresque vous verrez
ménardeau ce sera une affaire très le
dernier arbre le rôle du commissaire
dans les cinq dernières minutes c'est
pierre santini
mais france 2 arrête la série pourtant
il a su garder lui aussi le tour du flip
calme non violent en dehors et 1967
un autre commissaire va laisser son
empreinte sur vos écrans comme le
commissaire bourrel il est lui aussi
inséparable de sa pipe
pendant 25 ans il va incarner l'un des
plus célèbres flics de la télévision
jean-richard dans le commissaire maigret
ou jetés pu complètement fou alors il
complètement les oiseaux puis ce sera
bruno cremer qui aujourd'hui encore sur
france 2 un quart de mega man monté de
la bière et du tabac gris n'avait pas
arrangé vous pour en avoir
c'est donc en 1975 que le commissaire
moulin n'arrive sur petit écran
il a 30 ans à l'époque tu vois le chien
c'est finalement le le plus jeune flic
la télévision française on va quand même
aller loire ce commissaire moulin début
moi j'étais en costume cravate avec un
col à bouffer de la tarte une cravate
avec un avro depuis très très longue
tu vois tout ce qui était à la mode dans
les années soixante dix 75 quoi et puis
j'avais des pantalons pattes d'eph quand
j'ai repris le truc ça me gave est un
peu quoi de jouer le flic enquêteurs
parce que ce type de policiers à par
colombo qui a trait vraiment un
personnage très particulier et c'est
vrai c'est ce que dit toujours ma femme
ce type de policier c'est pas des rôles
intéressants tant qu'acteur quoi c'est
drôle tu poses des questions mais dit ne
t'inquiète pas tu es tu es tu es avec un
acteur passif les dépôts tu regardes
banquette évoluer autour de toi mais tu
aies jamais impliqué dedans c'est pareil
toi qui l'a révélé des problèmes et
toujours aux autres
thales que moi si tu veux que je tourne
maintenant c'est impliquant pour
lui-même parce que je te dire ce sont
des des trucs pour lesquelles il prend
fait et cause quoi alors moulin 7
plateaux de votre job a le blues
mais les méthodes sa grâce au petit
black
ouais j'y pense c'est vachement oui des
cantons la drogue et tu enfiles de
l'hérault un gain d'un point view 3 cuil
c'est vrai que mon âne souvent accusé
d'être un peu violent il utilise parfois
son revolver c'est le boulot des flics
sort mais il faut bien qu'ils les
utilisent peu world
quand j'ai commencé la télévision j'ai
commencé les premiers moulins
c'était quand même symptomatique quand
on regardait le texte à chaque fois il y
avait des mères dont ne faisait remplacé
par du proc
vous voyez un petit peu maintenant là si
tu n'as coup dans un film policier un
moulin le tipi socrates pour flûte
zut excusez moi et tous vous vous
imaginez un petit peu ça serait pas
tenable
derrière mais c'est pas possible il a il
absolument pas évolué donc je crois que
vous voulez mais les moulins bons petits
parfois on dit que grossier et vulgaire
mais je ne suis pas grosse ligne
c'est comme ça que s'expriment les flics
un achat l'homme jeu
moi monsieur ces moulins tête de neuf
sur france 2 tout scène d'une série
policière à haute teneur en hémoglobine
ou en sexe doit être filmé de façon à
pouvoir être coupée au montage
art sur tf1 ils ont trouvé une autre
parade un moulin très proche de réalité
on oppose navarro y avoir c'est là que
ça se passe